[Musique]
la journée des aidents s'est déroulée ce
jeudi 6 octobre au village coraille à
Saint-Gilles un moment de détente et de
partage pour ses aidans familiau qui
s'occupe au quotidien de personnes âgées
ou
handicapé pour avoir visité donc pas mal
de gramoun parce que je fais ça toutes
les semaines je visite les gramounes je
vois vraiment le travail que font ses
aidentss et c'est pour ça que je
soutiens le GP SAP qui porte cette
journée aujourd'hui et j'espère que tous
les ans il y aura une journée dédiée aux
aidans il le mérite fortement et
j'espère que ça va continuer et que les
gramoun seront traités comme il se doit
au programme de la journée divers
ateliers de détente mais aussi des
stands d'informations pour répondre aux
questions des aidans cette journée c'est
une journée de rencontre d'information
et de le partage entre les aidentss et
les professionnels on a démarré avec une
conférence donc une conférence qui est
animée donc par Monsieur Mathieu elgard
donc de l'Association française des
aidans et suivra cette conférence divers
ateliers de bien-être et des stands
d'information stand d'information qui
sont donc situé juste sur sur le site et
stand sur lequel les aidants pourront
avoir toutes les informations
nécessaires sur les aides pour eux-mêmes
et pour leurs proches une journée très
appréciée des aidants familiaux qui leur
permet d'échanger de rompre avec un
quotidien parfois difficile ben ça nous
permet de faire des rencontres de passer
une très bonne journée tout est bien
organisé ben ça ça nous fait plaisir
d'être avec les autres et en ayant plus
ou moins les mêmes problèmes mais ça
nous fait un temps de partage tout le
monde dans la vie on a besoin aussi de
temps en temps de penser à soi donc de
se faire plaisir et une journée comme ça
bah c'est formidable on peut permettre
de voir des choses d'apprendre des
choses à l'écoute des gens faire
beaucoup de choses quoi et comme c'est
mon frère je viens là pour accompagner
mon frère et je TR c'est bien c'est
important pour nous personne âé sachant
les idé çaendre beaucoup de chos par ex
diabète on a fait pu pour comment les
masses ça on va
bientôire une journée de détente et de
partage en soutien aux aidants familiaux
grâce à qui le maintien à domicile des
personnes âg handicapé est
possible
[Musique]